are you kind of welcome chaos at first
as the the power of my creativity and
then by itself with a little help from
me the chaos becomes order and then of
course I have a plan and i acquire the
ingredients that the plan needs like a
you know like making a dish one good way
to put chaos into order is and it works
for me and one should try it maybe it
works for you two is to make a list a
list of subjects for example if I'm
about to write a book or a chapter of a
book on on something I'm going to put a
list of the thing that I have to talk
about and then the list becomes
unbearably long of course and how can
this stupid list which is an edited how
can at least can distill and help you as
a writer in my example to arrive to
starting to write clearly and sing
simply a passage of your book and well
then there is the process of editing so
maybe it's not editing maybe it's more
compressing or revisiting so i take this
ridiculous list and i start scratching
things that where they came from my mind
but are to be deleted or I start
associating those three items actually
the only one so I compress I associate I
cancel certain things or so of course
more words or more you know thoughts
would come and then at the end that list
becomes very naturally a blueprint a
synopsis a guideline and if you have a
blueprint for an architect you can start
doing a three-dimensional model to show
the constructor how you want your house
built so as a writer if you're a
synopsis you can start writing because
it's a skeleton of your thoughts it
distilled things I think personally my
head is really exploding in all
direction when I am about to embark into
let's say a piece of writing you can
hear in my voice I am getting excited
talking about what people sometimes have
fear which
a blank surface or a blank calling and
what can you do so that the list and
leather on the arrival reflection moment
is what I need to start being
intelligible on the page